>> Sean: JOINING US NOW WITH
REACTION TO THE EXPLOSIVE
MEMO, CHIEF COUNSEL FOR THE
AMERICAN CENTER FOR LAW AND
JUSTICE JAY SEKULOW.
I'M CALLING THIS THE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER CORRUPTION
CASE IN OUR LIFETIME.
THIS WAS ALL DESIGNED TO
IMPACT A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION AND AN INCOMING
I WANT TO GET YOUR GENERAL
THROUGHOUT FIRST.
>> WELL, YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE TIME LINE HERE, SEAN, TO
SHOW HOW DANGEROUS THE
PRECEDENT THAT'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED BY THE FBI.
JAMES COMEY AND THE FBI
ATTEMPTED TO GET A FISA
WARRANT IN THE SUMMER OF
2016.
THEY WERE NOT SUCCESSFUL.
THEY THEN MOVED IN OCTOBER
BY ADDING TO THEIR REQUEST
THE STEELE DOSSIER.
THEN THEY GET A FISA WARRANT
SO THAT FISA WARRANT IS
ISSUED.
IN JANUARY, BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT WAS SWORN IN JAMES
COMEY MEETS AND SAYS
DANGEROUS AND UNSOLICITED
DOSSIER.
THE PRESIDENT WAS NOT
UNINVESTIGATION AND THAT NOT
TO WORRY ABOUT THAT.
YET, SEVEN WEEKS BEFORE
THEN, HE OBTAINED A FISA
WARRANT BASED ON THAT
DOSSIER.
THEN IT WAS RENEWED A DAY
BEFORE THE INAUGURATION AND
THEN RENEWED SUBSEQUENTLY
THE CHAIN OF EVENTS.
AND THAT'S WHAT I WANT
PEOPLE TO FOCUS ON THE TIME
LINE HERE IS VERY, VERY NOT
ONLY DANGEROUS WHAT DID THEY
POLITICAL OPPOSITION
RESEARCH.
THEY DIDN'T SAY IT WAS
UNVERIFIED.
CHRIS STEELE LEAKED THE
INFORMATION TO A MEDIA
SOURCE.
THE FBI SAYS THEY CUT OFF
FORMAL RELATIONS TO THEM
DID.
WHAT THEY DID BUT ALSO WHAT
THEY DID TO THE COURT AND I
THINK ALL THAT HAS TO BE
REVIEWED OBVIOUSLY.
AND I THINK SPECIAL COUNSEL
IS NECESSARY TO REVIEW THIS
ENTIRE MATTER.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT EVEN
INCLUDING THE BRUCE OHR
SITUATION OR ANY OF THAT YOU
ADD ALL OF THAT TOGETHER, I
THINK IT NEEDS TO BE OUTSIDE
COUNSEL.
>> Sean: IF YOU KNOW THAT
THIS IS A DEMOCRATIC BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR DOSSIER, AND
YOU KNOW THE INFORMATION IS
FALSE, AND YOU DON'T
DISCLOSE THIS TO THE JUDGE
ON FOUR SEPARATE OCCASIONS,
PRETTY ANGRY ABOUT ALL OF
THAT.
>> YEAH.
SO, YOU KNOW, FIRST OF ALL,
50 USC REQUIRES ALL
APPLICATION FOR WARRANT,
MORE THAN THAT, I THINK
WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE IS, THE
FACT THAT THEY UTILIZED THIS
NOT KNOWING THE COURT OF THE
ENTIRE PROCESS OF WHAT WENT
TWICE, THEY DID IT THREE
THE PRESIDENT-ELECT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND SAYING,
HEY, THERE IS THIS DOSSIER
OUT THERE.
I'M NOT TRYING TO DO A J.
EDGAR HOOVER THOSE WORDS
JAMES COMEY'S WORDS.
I'M NOT TRYING TO DO A
HOOVER HERE.
IT'S UNVERIFIED.
IT'S SALACIOUS.
YOU ARE NOT UNDER
INVESTIGATION BUT, YET, HE
UTILIZED THAT AGAIN TO
OBTAIN THE WARRANT IT
DOESN'T WORK BOTH WAYS.
>> Sean: YOU ARE SAYING HE
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP
UNVERIFIED AND SALACIOUS
DOSSIER.
TWO MONTHS EARLIER HE USED
TO GET THE WARRANT TO SPY ON
SO THE LEVEL OF DUPLICITY,
WHICH IS IT?
BECAUSE IF YOU THOUGHT IT
WAS UNVERIFIED.
>> YOU DON'T GET BOTH.
>> Sean: UNVERIFIED AND
SALACIOUS AND PRESENT IT TO
A COURT AND SIGNED OFF ON IT
AND THAT WAS DETERMINATIVE
FACTOR AS YOU POINT OUT
DENIED FIRST IN JULY, JAMES
COMEY HAS A BIG LEGAL
CHRISTOPHER STEELE CAME TIME
FRAME JULY.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, THE
SO-CALLED BRITISH SPY THAT
WAS GETTING THIS
INFORMATION, BY THE WAY, WHO
WAS WORKING ON IT WITH HIM?
BRUCE OHR, NUMBER FOUR, HIS
WIFE WHO HAPPENS TO BE
WAS A NEED FOR A SPECIAL
COUNSEL, THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE MOMENTS.
BECAUSE, UNFORTUNATELY AGAIN
THIS IS NOT THE RANK AND
FILE FBI MEMBERS.
THIS ISN'T DEEP STATE AS
PEOPLE CALL IT THIS IS THE
TOP.
THIS IS LEADERSHIP.
SO, AGAIN, YEAH, JAMES COMEY
DOESN'T GET IT BOTH WAYS.
HE CAN'T MAKE THE STATEMENTS
HE MADE AND THEN GO BACK ON
THEM TO GET A WARRANT.
HE GOT A WARRANT BASED ON
THIS INFORMATION AND I DON'T
CARE IF SOMEBODY IS A
REPUBLICAN, DEMOCRAT,
INDEPENDENT, LIBERTARIAN
GREEN PARTY, THAT'S NOT THE
WAY IT WORKS IN THE
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO THE
VERY END OF THE MEMO WHEN
THEY TALK ABOUT ANDREW
SURVEILLANCE WARRANT WOULD
HAVE BEEN SOUGHT FROM THE
FISA COURT BUT FOR THE
DOSSIER INFORMATION.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TRIED TO
JUMP ON THAT AND SAY OH, HE
DIDN'T EXACTLY SAY THAT
WELL, I CHECKED WITH
NUMEROUS SOURCES ON THE
ASKED THIS QUESTION MULTIPLE
TIMES AND ACTUALLY HIS
CASE.
THAT, IN FACT, THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE SOUGHT THIS IN ANY WAY
JAY.
YOU HAVE GOT HILLARY
CLINTON, BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
AND OF ALL THINGS DOSSIER
THINK ABOUT IT.
>> AND MCCABE VERY
SIGNIFICANT.
>> Sean: OKAY.
BUT IT'S TO LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
INFLUENCE THE ELECTION WHICH
RACHINGTS UP THE TYPICAL
>> THIS IS DONE BY FBI
DIRECTOR WHO, REMEMBER,
DEMOCRATS WERE CALLING FOR
HIS REMOVAL WHEN HE
INTERVENED BY THE WAY I WAS
VERY CRITICAL OF HIS
INTERVENTION IN THE
POLITICAL PROCESS.
I THOUGHT IT WAS ABSURD WHEN
HE DID THAT THREE STUNT
MANEUVER IN THE SUMMER AND
THE FALL IN THE ELECTION
AGAINST THE FBI WHERE HE
CONFLATED HIS JOB AS FBI
IS NOT HIS FUNCTION
ADMINISTRATIVELY OR
THAT.
BUT THIS IS WHAT HE DID.
GO BACK AND REMIND
THEMSELVES WHAT THEY SAID A
YEAR AGO, A YEAR AND A HALF
OF THIS, JAY SEKULOW?
>> WELL, THERE'S THE
QUESTION.
THE QUESTION IS, DID THIS
DOSSIER LEAD TO THIS --
CREATE THIS INVESTIGATION?
SIGNIFICANT LEGAL
CONSEQUENCE.
THAT IS THE UNDERLYING
QUESTION.
DID THIS IN THIS CASE FISA
WARRANT START THIS
INVESTIGATION?
AND, AGAIN, I CAN'T OPINE ON
I WILL TELL YOU THIS IT
IF I WAS GENERAL FLYNN
TONIGHT AND MY LAWYERS, I
SAME WITH PAUL MANAFORT.